am letzten montag ging es im kanzleramt
bei frau merkel endlich mal um ein
wichtiges thema nämlich um mein essen
angela merkel hat da die vertreter der
vier großen supermarktketten quasi
vorgeladen wegen ihrer viel zu niedrigen
preise denn unter denen leiden die
bauern zum glück haben deutschlands
landwirte aber eine sehr mächtige
verbündete landwirtschaftsministerin
julia klöckner für mich so was wie die
mutter courage der nation das ist
wahnsinn wie die sich reinhängt wie
diese freiheit für ihre leute jetzt zu
den fakten tatsächlich liegen unsere
lebensmittelpreise im europäischen
mittelfeld was aber stimmt die bauern
kriegen davon viel zu wenig ab und wer
schuld ganz einfach sie sind schuld der
doofe deutsche verbraucher als
verbraucher haben wir ungeahnte
möglichkeiten
wir zeigen sie ihnen sie entscheiden du
willst mich nicht für dich immer noch
sie zweitens alles auf den verbraucher
schieben ist nun auch ein bisschen
billig finde ich nenne das problem liegt
ja viel tiefer unsere bauern kriegen
deswegen so wenig weil die
ernährungsindustrie massenhaft für den
weltmarkt produzieren soll
was hier passiert das ist quasi so was
wie schweine nach china tragen wirklich
ja darüber
darüber redet oder sich unser julien
ungern aber dafür kann sie echt gut
rechnen edeka will jetzt anbieten zwei
kilogramm äpfel für sage und schreibe 1
eur 11 2 kilogramm erfüllte 1 eur 11 42
kilo äpfel 1 eur 11 2 kilo äpfel nur 1
eur 11 um den fall zu klären wurde eine
sonderkommission apfel mit rund 220
ermittlern gegründet sorry ich musste
schon noch wenig äpfel kaufen gibt es
für 1 euro
ja
das hat mir irgendwie erzählt
eur 11,8 er gewinnen natürlich natürlich
bestimmen aldi lidl rewe und edeka die
deutschen preise
dem gehören 85 prozent unserer
supermärkte hat die politik ja auch
zugelassen
doch nun landvolk atmet auf denn im
kanzleramt wurde folgendes beschlossen
supermärkte sollen freiwillig anfangen
die bauern fairer zu behandeln
toll außerdem richtet frau klöckner eine
zitat beschwerdestelle 1
falls das mit der freiwilligkeit nicht
klappt dabei handelt es sich wohl um
eine milchkanne in die wütenden bauern
ihre beschwerde rein sprechen dürfen
aber hauptsache immer schön ran wanzen
an die landbevölkerung julia sie kommt
ja selber vom land ich weiß dass auch
von mir verwandtschaft irgendwo dabei
ist vielleicht sehe ich wenn es mir mal
winken also sind die peckelsheimer ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich zu sehen wo sind
sie da hinten ja genau
huhu peckelsheimer warum hälfte der weg
ja weil die sich für die schäden julia
weil die sich für die schemen wirklich
dieses run wanze nächte gehabt
irgendwann weingut und macht den ganzen
tag ein auf bäuerin glaubt jedoch keine
sau juliaca gibt die bodenständige
bäuerin die trecker fahren und stöcke
durchschneiden kann unser volk heute bei
klöckner bauernfänger ich selbst komme
aus der landwirtschaft ich selbst komme
aus einem weingut mich ist heimat ein
stück geruch auch heu ach ja für mich
riecht dass er nach busches versteckte
kamera aufnahmen zeigen wie weingut
erbin mehrfach in diesem berliner
gebäude ein recherche verbund aus ndr
zdf und bauer sucht frau vermutet es
handelt sich um den bundestag wo julia k
im sogenannten kabinett die felgen zieht
für deutschlands fackel verarbeitende
industrie das zdf schickt seinen besten
investigativ reporter
sind sie wollen ja ich hatte eine
lieblings ziege nach acht monaten finden
sie in einer nervenheilanstalt als wir
sie auch julia k ansprechen reagiert sie
hysterisch und nächste woche arbeitet
diese codes auch eigentlich als
verteidigungsministerin und warum merkt
man davon nichts
[Applaus]
aber die spannende frage ist ja was tun
gegen dumping im supermarkt keiner mag
ja eingriffe des staates in frankreich
zum beispiel müssen lebensmittelpreise
mindestens 10 prozent über dem
einkaufspreis liegen zumindest laut
umfragen wäre der deutsche verbraucher
theoretisch bereit mehr für fleisch zu
bezahlen wenn die tiere dafür weniger
gequält werden
in umfragen in den allermeisten stellen
herrscht derweil immer noch zustände wie
im horrorfilm ist wirklich war wie im
horrorfilm neulich bei einer greenpeace
stichprobe karmann sogenannten
frischetheken im supermarkt 88 prozent
88 prozent des fleisches aus den
untersten haltung stufen tierwohl kostet
geld und wir würden wenn der verbraucher
bereit ist das abzurufen und zu brutal
über viel mehr machen
wir können jede schweinebucht dennoch in
wirbelau namen es muss der verbraucher
letztlich nicht nur bezahlen und nicht
wir
klingt gut schweine im whirlpool ich
will jetzt nicht klugscheißern aber
vielleicht wäre es denen schon luxus
genug wenn man sie mit betäubung
kastriert da passt es ins bild dass frau
klöckner zum discounter gipfel keine
fleischproduzenten eingeladen hat weil
man die massentierhaltung bei uns
natürlich nie infrage stellen darf
dazu begrüße ich jetzt den sprecher des
verbandes der essbaren paarhufer mit
schnitzel hintergrund sie waren jetzt
auch gar nicht eingeladen oder
gut er kann schweinchen schlau
wahrscheinlich abend die kleine klöckner
dass ihr vor lauter dankbarkeit für ihr
freiwilliges tierwohl label schön auf
den tisch gepackt hätte und zwar
freiwillig geht ihnen nicht weit genug
das label alter die klöckner hat neulich
noch per verordnung dafür gesorgt dass
man uns noch weitere 15 jahre in diesen
boxen halten darf hast du die teile mal
gesehen welche last von dir nicht mal
ein oberschenkel rein was wäre also ihre
botschaft an die agrarministerinnen da
reicht eine geste ja sorry ich hab
keinen mittelfinger macht nix ein
enttäuschtes schwein meine damen und
herren
es ginge auch anders es ginge auch
anders in großbritannien und schweden
zum beispiel sind solche engen
kastenstände so nennt man die seit
vielen jahren verboten es geht schon
fleisch und co müssen auch für arme
leute erschwinglich sein sagt die groko
und das ist völlig richtig
absolut richtig klar man könnte auch mal
den hartz-iv-satz erhöhen aber wir
lassen das lieber so wie es ist dass man
sich immer entscheiden muss zwischen
tier oder mensch es kann bei uns leider
nur einem gut geht so wir schalten mal
live zu valerie niehaus sprecherin von
edeka sie gibt nämlich jetzt gerade eine
pressekonferenz zum supermarkt äpfel ich
schlage vor wir haben einfach mal rein
ja so meine damen und herren wir können
loslegen
im namen der edeka- gruppe weise ich die
vorwürfe unserer
landwirtschaftsministerin entschieden
zurück einer ganzen branche unfaire
geschäftspraktiken vorzuwerfen als wären
wir irgendwie halbseiden oder unseriös
ich hab das eben noch zu unserem
justitia hier gesagt der ist menschlich
auch enttäuscht und wir möchten beide
der frau klöckner sagen sie möge doch
bitte ihre worte in zukunft besser
abwägen weil wir wissen wo sie wohnt
so jetzt auch fragen von ihrer seite ja
ich hatte eine viel sie das denn ok wie
sie zusammen mit lidl aldi und rewe die
preise bestimmen
das ist ja für obstbau und teilweise
bitter denn die haben ja auch
produktionskosten 40 bis 70 cent kostet
ihn das pro kilo äpfel in manchen jahren
erhält er aber je nach sorte nur 20 bis
30 cent pro kilo also weniger als ihm
der anbau kosten
das klingt jetzt hart wenn da einer so
gar keinen gewinn macht andererseits
zahlt man dann natürlich auch null
steuern na das ist ja nun ja und stimmt
das denn das regionale erzeuger ihn geld
zahlen müssen um überhaupt in ihr
sortiment zu kommen ja ja klar wir
nennen das schutz einstiegsgeld es nur
fair denn die bauern profitieren ja auch
von unserer infrastruktur was wir hier
alles haben strom regale
was ist denn daran unseriös wir sehen
die bauern immer als partner auf
augenhöhe
ja was ist denn jetzt stellt doch hinein
große mengen bestellen die etwa bei
einem lieferanten zu einem niedrigen
preis nehmen dann aber deutlich weniger
ab als vereinbart der preis allerdings
bleibt wie vereinbart die ketten kommen
damit durch weil sie so mächtig sind
was nehme ich denn hier den nehme ich
und den nehme ich den rest kann sich
damit neben halt so und morgen nehme ich
dann drei tonnen kohlrabi vielleicht
noch mal ist es richtig dass edeka von
obstbauern in norddeutschland neulich
zwei prozent von deren jahresumsatz
nachträglich zurückgefordert hat um
damit das 100 jährige edita
firmenjubiläum zu finanzieren zur
kollege jetzt ist hier mal ende gelände
ja du hörst jetzt sofort auf den
deutschen supermärkten hier quasi ja so
zuhälter methoden zu unterstellen
und das sage ich nicht alleine das sage
ich auch im namen der anderen großen
drei rewe aldi und lidl wäre ich mit
einem von uns anlegt legt sich mit allen
an nicht aus meine damen und herren
alter der club hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn inhaltlich stark satire comedy
grotte
ich habe es noch drauf also ich würde
den kanal direkt abonnieren und auf
gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das nicht
schon getan hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]